your performance in I Tonya you played
Tonya Harding's mom and it is such an
incredible performance because you keep
looking for this character first of all
I've never seen a character quite like
her and we'll start with the fact that
many of your scenes you have a bird on
your shoulder I do because this is
something that Tonya Harding's mom yeah
I wouldn't believed it but my my friend
Steven Rogers who wrote this great
scripts sent me the script I read it and
I said what an interesting look you've
gotten together for her mother how did
you come up with that why a bird why a
fur coat that's so specific and odd and
and he sent me this clip of a
documentary that someone did about Tonya
Harding and her mother's in it with a
fur coat and the bird and the bowl
haircut and the glasses and I wouldn't
have believed it was it was but that is
exactly that was the look she went for
and it's clear that you see the movie
you're there and I know that just just
part of the job is doing multiple takes
trying different things you have a real
bird on your shoulder the whole time how
did you were you okay with that well I
did I I had to audition three birds and
I didn't let any I did actually I went
around back I think we were in the you
know in the parking lot of a 7-eleven
somewhere in Atlanta and this woman was
there with the bird handler with all the
birds and I was like it felt like a drug
deal we were going on in the back and
yeah I'm not to equate say oh gee I just
do a bad thing there okay all right I'm
sorry that's for all thought deals
happen 7-eleven
see ya three birds and I took each one
out and I'm I'm a dog and cat person I
don't know birds they kind of freak me
out but I wanted to appear like it was
okay we're gonna do the birds now I'm
gonna touch birds and here we go and and
one bird was to squawk II was really
just to talk too much I was like next I
don't want that one and then I don't
want him to steal the scene from me and
then the next bird decided he left my
hair he was crawling all around it and
got his cause stuck in my hair and I was
like I don't like this guy and then then
finally and the third one was just the
third one his name little man and he
just sat there and he's really quiet he
was really
I said this guy this guy want this guy
and then we get into the filming this is
kind of a long story but but you know I
smoked through the whole movie yes and
the bird handler says right before we
shoot the scene you can't smoke around
the bird and and Craig Gillespie our
director said well she she has to smoke
she's been smoking is part of your
character yeah and I said wait it was
actually the one idea that came up with
that like I saved the day because I
looked at the prop Department I said do
you guys have a you know those breathing
tubes and an oxygen tank and the guys
they were like yes we do I was and it
was kind of a miracle that they did
because it wasn't called for in this
movie anywhere oh you added that yeah
yeah I added it said so so she has
emphysema which makes absolute sense
that she's been smoking all the earlier
scenes she is smoking and then when
you're with the birds I have the oxygen
tank and the breathing tube whatever
it's called and the bird that was the he
decided he was fascinated by that
plastic tube so he kept poking at it
yeah in my ELISA was right in my ear and
he was just poke poke poking and I was
just trying to you know stop him I knew
we didn't have time to really stop and
tell him not to
you can't tell a bird not to poke it in
I mean I yes you can you don't do it
your agent does it that's how it's
that's how it's done in this town the
bird gets a call yeah I didn't have any
time to deal with it so I just had to
work with it that's it I usually do as
an actor it's okay I'm gonna work with
it and I just looked in the camera and
told my story and was not gonna let him
knock me off my plate right and then
occasionally I turned to him and say
shut up yeah and it was you know but I
kind of and in the end I think he fueled
my performance and yeah gave me a bet
the bird was watching you win the Golden
Globe and it's like
you